have you ever almost died
uh yes tell me
well i i i could have
you mean like had i did i get close to
the light
no no no not an nde as they're known
near-death experience but maybe when you
were a kid were you ripped out in a
riptide
oh sure anything like that oh sure i was
on a horse once and the horse got
spooked and took off and my dad was like
oh
[__]
[Laughter]
well when we cut to you it's in real
time he's in slow motion i don't want to
micromanage but you're like
you're knocking apples off trees
hitting apples from your head
you are i was here i'm gone i was
stressed
no that did happen
but how did it stop
i think did you read up i think somebody
caught up with me i don't remember i was
once driving up to my my dear friend uh
brook clayman and i were driving up to
college you know brooke clayman no it's
just it was so important oh wow
well clearly you're not as cool as i
thought you were
this guy knew brooke clayman brooke is a
wonderful family friend
known for many years and i wanted
someone to drive up back to college with
me i went to uc santa cruz and it's a
long drive and i i don't like big drives
by myself yeah especially i was a young
man horseback especially in horseback
had my had my jetta my my my uh
yeah we uh we were on the two-lane thing
i was driving and then like a semi
i don't know what happened but somebody
came my lane and i veered but you're
supposed to like turn into the swerve
but i just didn't and so the car just
like
did a did a 180 and so i was driving
backwards on the oh on the
highway and i remember looking at the
semi and the semi looking at me and i
was just like going backwards and then
and then oh my god and back around the
other 180 and then we just kind of and
went to the curb and we were just sort
of like frozen i think it's because my
car was so packed down with all my [__]
for my apartment that i was thinking
about yeah so we just
we should have flipped
like kitty litter that's what i always
say
and um and it just got quiet because you
know when you get scared like i i i
didn't hear any sound but then slowly i
started hearing what was on the radio
and it was like
don't you worry about a fight
it was we were listening to stevie
wonder don't worry about a thing it was
so perfect and weird it was such a weird
life experience and it came back on just
so loud
so it had been blasting i didn't hear it
at all of course
there are things in movies that are
right yeah you know what anything like
that feels like a movie like when it
goes
yeah like something happens
i love it so much w
everyone does it the ringing is so good
though the ringing is great but i meant
when someone's like
um i'm sorry but you have a week to live
it starts to fall and it starts to fade
out
yeah and then yeah
we can take the resources yes to a
little tonight and the resources of
listening go into grief go into shock
well it's it's fight or flight of course
or freezer friend
have you heard friend
no reuben from all time yeah we hang out
clearly because he's got a red beard i
mean but not a weasley beard
no one no one has a green beard get
those [__] walk away those guaca
walkers out of here something i used to
say on stage although i get to get sad
when one of them
almost died am i ruining it for you in
harry potter yeah oh i've seen the
movies they just don't stick
you know why because you know why
because you love the hob do me a fave no
i i yeah i am more of a tolkien are you
did you read the books and that was like
your childhood and then you got into the
movies
just the movies just the movies my dad
was really into the books when we were
kids do me a fave okay
h potter yeah it's too much
it's a it's a a gun
or a sword yeah these are established
realities sure but once you have sticks
that shoot beams of light of varying
strengths yeah uh that are hinged on a
mechanism that we don't understand
magical concentration question mark now
i have voldemort going like
and harry potter going
i'm like this is bad filmmaking
like it just is i two two people pushing
against each other a car pushing against
something a loud sound but as soon as
it's
i'm like i'm out and that's what harry
potter ultimately is it's like in star
trek there's too much of this
yeah yeah
i stopped watching star trek a long time
ago i it wasn't for me i was big star
wars lady so i didn't care i didn't
really care about star trek yes not that
you needed to pick a side but like it
wasn't for me i think you did need i did
pick a side when you were you have you
never wasn't i was i on star wars were
you in star wars
i'm laughing so hard are you on this
original star wars yeah that's just how
i call you 70.
weren't you in the original star wars
i'm carrie fisher
i
[Music]
oh wish